hello and welcome no not Queen Queen
spawn welcome to this blitz video
Forever Young is my opponent not getting
away with this okay this is interesting
both taking and ninety of three is good
an idea three is a fleet warm ok yeah
this is a line which nets white they're
small but they re persistent advantage
our Queen d7 okay I think you still take
this should be seven is a bit more
common okay I do mind if he takes on d5
that knight on d5 will be well placed
you know probably just castle
it is a symmetrical porn structure and
one that in fact rather often can dry
out but the more active pieces they
count for something
okay so here we should be five certainly
possible
no going to do that all yeah I guess
sometimes you can maybe just take on c6
and make a spawn structure questionable
even though yeah
Bishop g4 is possible
yeah that's a good move I don't like to
have my pawn structure weakened like
that yeah probably Bishop e5 was not the
best idea ever
yep that is like him that is not great
but I don't know I guess he has to take
maybe he can give me the pawn down on c6
but not certain okay intermediate
okay now I'm going to go here I have to
be careful not if it could be
embarrassing I just want to be as active
as possible and now maybe try to get the
bishop to g3 and then maybe fy5 at okay
I did not really did not have this on
the radar look one d3 is not good either
it's not c5
hmm that's it's really not good I played
this quite badly I don't know what
exactly my mistake was
trajan 195 was maybe annoyingness is why
I am played this
yeah it's it's not much fun he even has
94 kind of questionable is that that's
much okay now he has played himself into
a pin down on the e-file it does not
need necessarily need to be a big
problem like it could could become one
Bishop takes his seven as as impossible
to you but I can also just take take
this pawn it's still a bit of a problem
for him to movie success I'm on this on
a seven and c7
I can't keep all this covered ruk c6 is
also a threat it was possible to play it
immediately but there's no particular
reason to rush this rookie 7 now is a
threat
I would see three are okay we did not
play it
Oh
little it was I should really pay
attention to the age porn
yeah this is not ideal obviously bird
ice got to see he's got Luke age three
oh what a lockbox
unbelievable he totally stumbled into
this stuff
great that's a pain why on earth you I
can't go anywhere King b1 or anything
okay well it was a really terrible game
from start to finish that's really
annoying okay anyway so this is kind of
normal I guess
Luke he won he took it 96 and from here
um I should improve
there should be five it's already not
that great Bishop f4 is the engine
suggestion and it makes quite a bit of
sense here as ninety five now becomes
more of a problem the dangers of lucky
is to get into some end game that is
just eternally worse due to assemble
should be five take c6 or he's just not
active then the engines advantage he is
already quite substantial it gives 0.7
okay this is this is not not all that
fantastic I guess the engine wants to
take with the rook surprisingly
I'm surprised maybe I mean something
something like that can never be can
never be is super for me I'm surprised
that the engine is even giving me an
edge when in the game we had a similar
situation just with two rocks and here I
felt it was more of an issue yeah yeah
now he systematically outplayed himself
basically by giving me pins and
everything Jim I'm surprised that this
is not good for white really why he
cannot move you cannot miss the rookie
cannot move the knight how can that be
good for black so take take and what is
he and what is the engines justification
here it wants to check and then play
would be five okay I go see three and it
goes see five so it basically says that
untangling as possible yeah here there
is there's this museum that is a bit a
bit a bit of a problem
threatening made
okay so it wasn't that good actually
I asked tomato disposition to be just
clearly better for white because he
cannot move but if if he has those ideas
like him okay the engine mentions this
because of this idea and now wookie
eight and black is just about in time to
untangle with this yeah okay so that
wasn't all that grade
yeah hey all this isn't isn't super
convincing really for me take take and
now Lucas is seven is actually wrong
best is Ruby three you just keep the
tension yeah well here we both them
didn't have much time and there were
certainly mistakes but okay I just have
to win this position I mean it's not
really excusable that I didn't yeah that
was blundering rooks III which he didn't
play I should play Bishop deform I mean
this is this is very dangerous on its
own I don't really need to look them
yeah I mean the whole game was a bit of
a what's really bad no yeah I mean I saw
this move but g3 I was thinking oh I
have this came then this is was clearly
the best move because I'm dominating the
night and he cannot do anything against
us but I didn't see that after g3 this
was hanging so okay so then here now
queer then now King c3 on almost this is
such an I mean how I mean I was just
this first whatever and it
this was the app I just gifted him this
one was the only way to do this game and
I found it very reliably the average
twenty pound pound one loss is really is
really terrible okay I need to warm up I
guess the first game of a session is
always a bit problematic thanks for
watching